duh dear mother I do you a few young we
are in our fourth year or war today it
is September the third 1943 even nothing
we report news oh yeah we've come your
letter arrived here on Sunday twenty
second of august ish da can be them
didn't get the gooseberries with
unconditional announced parcel it was
only handed to me yesterday english i
most likely brought here by foot taught
ya in its contact and two pounds of
apples and they starve your rotten mass
of foul-smelling revenir puri warden
Matthias is devoured with the ravenous
appetite oh I know hun flow another
handful of something far to run that was
fought over by a few other dune men when
is she the woman nobody believed to my
descriptions of fun starve but this one
who has to be believed because everybody
can see the truth for themselves oh so
not after having written two letters
heinen and 12 power from Baris teen I
sent you the news of our being moved
here nothing stays before the transport
but if you don't love you would but
asking for your visit yeah the transfer
took place on july twenty six pin and
water on monday you know that it will be
exactly six weeks since i got here via
wooden egan be right now because of the
planes and dad because here and this is
variously populated region really it is
possible to starve us without attracting
attention London wash diamond of the bar
Stein inmates who came with me to this
killing center even only a few are still
alive we mentioned
here people are reduced to skin and
bones and are dying like flies patiently
yeah approximately 30 people die every
week money their skin covered bones are
buried without a coffin good pictures of
people starving in India or Russia are
now my reality you could get Umi because
she'd our daily diet consists of two
slices of bread with jam the occasional
way with margarine udo sometimes without
anything mid the lunch and dinner life
is three-quarters of a liter of water
with potato slices and when string g
scraps of cabbage the men she human
beings behave like animals eating
anything you can get from others though
even raw potatoes and mango yeah indeed
a good look we wouldn't be capable of
eating other things like the prisoners
in Russia deal will go toward the
starvation is breathing down our necks
kind of nobody knows who will be next
you're before you think they used to
kill people who work in this region and
carry thing move to incineration at dawn
earth when the local community protested
that may simply decided to starve us
really we are living in calm down wounds
una without radio so newspapers and
books yeah in fact wouldn't without any
kind of occupation how I miss my
handiwork alone
via its weight from broken dishes we're
closed and thin Warren rags in which
I've already been colder than in an
entire winter in Hagen woof my last path
was five weeks ago hearted and nobody
knows if we will have another bath this
year I love every two weeks we are given
a clean shirt and socks does that is
socialism indeed oh yeah yeah your inst